[Music]
today is the one year anniversary of the
best worst day of your life the best
part was discovering a subterranean city
on mars the first evidence of
intelligent alien life ever found the
worst part no one got to explore it
because that was when you lost contact
with earth
you and the other 99 scientists have
spent the rest of the year engineering
your survival but you're almost out of
water and solutions
everyone else is at the ice cap but
you've decided to investigate the buried
city to see if there are clues to how
their civilization survived on a desert
planet
the city is mostly ruins except for
three intact pyramids two open and one
sealed in the first you find a series of
symbols and pictograms revealing a
fortuitously base 10 numbering system
the second pyramid's facade is covered
in these symbols inside you discover a
device as well as mosaic representations
of how to use it from those you glean
the following the device is the key to
opening the sealed pyramid by inputting
the number on the center block but if
you put in the wrong number something
terrible and deadly will happen the
doors to all pyramids work on the same
principle
what number should you input to open the
door to the sealed pyramid
[Music]
the pattern revealed by the second
pyramid is that every number is the sum
of the two numbers directly beneath it
if that applies to the sealed pyramid 40
clearly belongs to the left of 30. the
center number is the sum of seven and an
unknown call it x
the value of x can be determined by
trial and error but it's quicker to use
algebraic reasoning
the number to the left of the center
number is 5 plus x therefore this block
40 is equal to 5 plus x plus 7 plus x
solving for x x must be 14 making the
central block 21.
you enter 21 on the remote and the door
opens
inside you find yet another riddle the
walls show the history of this
civilization
when they lived here the planet was
covered with oceans but at a certain
point they up and left mars
in order to reserve the planet for
themselves while making it inhospitable
to others they moved all the water
underground using a gigantic engineering
marvel activated by a single lever
the lever is hidden in the great pyramid
pulling the lever again would reverse
the process and bring the water back to
the surface
but where is this great pyramid the
mosaics indicate it should be right here
but it's clearly not without it you have
no choice but to climb back out of the
city to the surface
and that's when you see it the city is
the final pyramid or at least one face
of it a great pyramid indeed
the city's architects must have designed
each district to show a number when
viewed from above but only these three
survived the ravages of time the key
once again must be whatever number was
in the center plaza you rush there but
what numbers should you input into the
remote
you could write out the algebra again
but here's a more visual approach
sketch a pyramid and enter the known
numbers between the 9 and the 10 you can
put colored dots to represent the two
unknowns at the bottom
working your way up the pyramid and
drawing the sums as you go will reveal
that 100 equals 19 plus three green dots
plus three orange dots
so three times green plus orange equals
eighty-one and green plus orange which
is the middle number must be
twenty-seven
you don't actually have to figure out
what green and orange are in fact they
have a number of possibilities when you
enter 27 a hidden mechanism opens in the
middle of the plaza revealing a
staircase
you descend and finally find yourself in
a room with a giant lever in the middle
only one question remains
do you pull it
while you make up your mind there's
another group of scientists who are in
desperate need of your quick wits
they've managed to get themselves stuck
in 11 separate dimensions yikes and it's
up to you to retrieve them from the
multiverse help them get home with this
video